ist es vielleicht nur ein zufälliges
rauschen oder handelt es sich
tatsächlich um die spuren eines
schwarzen lochs das aus einem anderen
universum stand ein internationales
forschungsteam ist sich sicher den geist
eines schwarzen lochs aufgespürt haben
dieses könnte demnach aus einem anderen
universum stall und schon längst
verschwunden sein
roth links und science fiction hier gibt
es täglich spannende science abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen man kann es
vielleicht mit manchen sternen
vergleichen die wir zwar von der erde
aussehen die aber schon längst nicht
mehr existieren ein forschungsteam der
universität warschau der oxford
university und dem new york maritim
college will jetzt quasi den geist eines
schwarzen lochs aufgespürt haben dieses
muss nach ansicht der fachleute aus
einem anderen universum stammen und
längst wieder verschwunden sein deswegen
handelt es sich auch nur noch um den
geist des schwarzen lochs gab es
möglicherweise vor uns also bereits
andere universen die ebenfalls wie unser
universum zahlreiche schwarze löcher
enthalten haben und ist es sogar möglich
spuren dieser längst verschwundenen
schwarzen löcher aufzuspüren das
forschungsteam beruft sich bei dieser
verblüffenden hypothese auf die
sogenannten hawking points sie das
mysteriöse schwarze loch eins spuren
hinterlassen habe dabei soll es sich
vereinfacht gesagt um stellen handeln an
denen noch überreste der hawking
strahlung vermutet werden sieben hawking
selbst hatte erkannt dass die oft als
staubsauger bezeichneten schwarzen
löcher nicht nur materie verschlucken
bis dahin haben die fachwelt an das
schwarzen löcher nicht einfach in gar
nichts entkommen kann
doch der physiker zeigt dass die
strahlung aussenden und letztlich
langsam verdampfen bis sie dann
irgendwann verschwunden sind heißt also
schwarze löcher halt nicht bis in alle
ewigkeit und das waren tatsächlich nicht
nur überraschende sondern sogar
revolution neuere erkenntnisse
diese strahlung wurde dann einige zeit
später als hawking strahlung bezeichnet
die fachleute die den geist des
mysteriösen schwarzen lochs aufgespürt
haben wollen gehen von den folgenden
annahmen aus sie sind der ansicht dass
schwarze löcher die masse des universums
aufsaugen und teilchen abgeben die über
keine masse
sogenannte gravy tonen und photonen
diese masse losen teilchen zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass sie sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen und raum
und zeit nicht wahrnehmen irgendwann
besteht dieser theorie zufolge das ganze
universum nur noch aus diesen speziellen
teilchen dann sei der zeitpunkt gekommen
an dem ein neues universum entsteht doch
die hawking strahlung sein diesen neu
gebildeten universum als überrest des
alten universums noch messbar dahinter
steckt also die annahme dass die
hintergrundstrahlung eines zerfallenden
loches auch noch dann vorhanden ist wenn
ein universum endet und ein neues
universum beginnt das universum aus dem
das längst verschwundene schwarze loch
stammen soll könnte nach angaben
deutlich älter sein als das universum in
dem wir gerade leben die fachleute
spekulieren dass es sich zudem auch noch
anderweitig von unserer universum
version unterscheiden könnte sogenannte
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung führte
die fachleute auf ihre spur diese
strahlung in der fachsprache auch als
cosmic microsoft background cmb
bezeichnen existiert wohl schon seit dem
zeitpunkt kurz nach dem urknall
das schwarze loch soll diese spezielle
strahlung hinterlassen haben ein
forscher der an dieser untersuchung
beteiligt war es roger penrose er war
ein wichtiger mitarbeiter von stephen
hawking und ist zudem ein verfechter
einer modifizierten version des urknalls
2010 hat er die sogenannte hypothese der
konformen zyklischen kosmologie
aufgestellt demnach bedeutet das ende
des einen universums den beginn des
nächsten universums dabei hinterlassen
schwarze löcher ihre spuren in den
folgenden universen panels beschreibt
seine entdeckung folgendermaßen es ist
nicht die singularität des schwarzen
lochs oder sein tatsächlicher physischer
körper sondern die gesamte hawking
strahlung des lochs während seiner
gesamten geschichte
demnach handelt es sich bei den nun
entdeckten spuren also gar nicht um ein
schwarzes loch an sich sondern um sein
bestreben über milliarden jahre hinweg
die energie in form von hawking
strahlung an das universum abzugeben das
schwarze loch hat sich dadurch stück für
stück aufgelöst und dabei spuren
hinterlassen dabei entstanden ist eine
markierung die den tod des jeweiligen
universums übersteht und sich in der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung
niederschlägt das forschungsteam will
seine hypothese mit einer gefälschten
karte untermauern die zufällig
generierte hintergrundstrahlung zeit mit
deren hilfe haben die experten und
expertinnen versucht ähnliche punkte im
universum zu reproduzieren
doch diese zufälligen daten bildeten das
phänomen nicht nach damit sehen die
beteiligten wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler ihre hypothese gestützt
doch unter experten und expertinnen ist
der aktuelle aufsatz durchaus umstritten
laut kritikerinnen und kritiker kann es
nämlich nicht ausgeschlossen werden dass
sie sich stattdessen um eine zufällige
zerstreuung kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung handelt wo kann ich
da nur sagen dass es extrem spannend
hawking strahlung nachgewiesen hier gehe
ich nochmal detailliert auf diese
mysteriöse strahlung ein anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren und natürlich die glocke
nicht vergessen bis dann bleibt dran